some breaking news coming in from from
brussels from the european commission
the european commission president ursula
fonda line
is due to make an ex a statement on
brexit
uh starting at any moment we are seeing
now live pictures from
brussels at the podium where she's
expected to begin her statement in
just a moment from now according to
irish national broadcaster rte
she's set to announce that the eu will
begin
legal action against the uk government
of prime minister boris johnson
for violations of the brexit withdrawal
agreement
for more now we go live to our
correspondent in brussels barbara basil
barbara what can we expect from this
statement
the deadline ran out last night because
the european union had said to boris
johnson okay listen you need to take
back
this internal market bill as it is
called in britain
because it is violating the withdrawal
agreement the point there is
that it would sort of take back and
annihilate
some of these special clauses that have
been made for
continuing trade in northern ireland and
boris johnson the british prime minister
now wants to step back on that and sort
of
shape this agreement that is a case of
international law
shape this agreement according to his
own tastes
and that is a no go go says the european
union now they've been mulling over
what to do in this case for quite a
while and it seems
now that they are going the legal route
they
seem to be prepared to take the united
kingdom
to the european court of justice and uh
and sue them there and say you are sort
of
going against the withdrawal agreement
there is a clause in there that says
both sides have to act in good will and
that is a breach this
particular bill that just passed the
parliament in london
this particular bill is a breach of that
clause
so they are really trying to play
hardball with boris johnson
and the interesting thing is here beside
all this the brexit negotiations are
going on in brussels i mean
negotiators are sitting in the very same
building that you see behind me
and they're still trying to bridge the
gaps between
the expectations and wishes of the two
sides so this is what all this is about
and
it seems that as you say the plot is
thickening here in brussels
indeed the plot is thickening barbara as
you say there are negotiations going on
still
between the eu and the uk uh
the the uk officially having left the
european union at the beginning of this
year at the end of january but
the negotiating the future trading
relationship
is something that is still to be worked
out what
would this step that we believe fondue
line is going to take the commission
she's about to begin let's listen in
to remove the problematic parts of their
draft internal
market bill by the end of september
this draft bill is by its very nature
a breach of the obligation of good faith
laid down in the withdrawal agreement
moreover if adopted as is
it will be in full contradiction to the
protocol of ireland
northern ireland the deadline lapsed
yesterday
the problematic provisions have not been
removed
therefore this morning the commission
has decided
to send a letter of formal notice to the
uk government this is the first step
in an infringement procedure
the letter invites the uk government to
send its
observations within a month
and besides this the commission will
continue to work hard
towards a full and timely implementation
of the withdrawal agreement we stand by
our commitments
thank you
and that was the eu commission president
ursula fonda
line lion stating that the european
union is now about to begin
legal proceedings against the united
kingdom
for a breach of articles of good faith
in
the withdrawal agreement our
correspondent barbara basils is standing
by for us in
brussels a brief statement there from
ursula fonda lion barbara
what can we read into it it's a warning
shot
towards london because clearly the eu
says basically if this bill comes into
legal force
and it still has some hurdles
particularly in the house of lords to
overcome
which was supposed to happen later this
year but if this bill
really legally comes into force we
cannot possibly
bring a trade agreement uh into
legal action because the two contradict
each other also how
much faith can we have in the united
kingdom
in the uh sort of the good will of the
united kingdom that they will
act according to international treaties
that they are
making with us the eu if they act like
this
so this was a breach of international
law that the british government
had announced in parliament a minister
stood up in parliament and said
yes this bill the so-called internal
market bill will breach international
law and there was a certain amount of
uproar but in the end the bill passed
without a hitch
that means that of course all
international partners now particularly
the european union say
how can we trust a country like that it
is a very serious breach
and it absolutely throws a very dark
light
over the ongoing trade talks and it
it somehow means that if britain doesn't
step back from the brink in that case
uh in the end a trade agreement cannot
really come into force
at the beginning of next year so ominous
all this very ominous
ursula van der laan said that this was
the first
step barbara in an infringement
procedure
has she left some wiggle room there for
the uk to still get out of this
uh this this internal market bill
to maybe not adopt that and to walk this
back and not breach international law
yes they could of course i mean there is
with the european union always wiggle
room in cases like this
so now now the the clock st starts
ticking
they they will get a letter they have
the chance to write a letter
back and say oh we're sorry we didn't
mean this like that
could we somehow agree that it never
happened whatever
face saving sort of formula they could
find possibly
to walk this back yes it is doable that
they will have to walk it back
because this is not unimportant this is
just not a legal detail
this is about the future of trade in
ireland and this is about keeping
borders in ireland open and keeping
northern ireland
tied to the internal market of the
european union because that's what the
two parties the uk
and the eu agreed to last year when the
withdrawal agreement was signed
so this has to be kept and of course the
european union is standing by ireland
where in dublin the government is of
course very nervous watching all these
shenanigans coming from london
so it is sort of coming to the point
where the two sides will really have to
decide particularly london will have to
decide
what do we want do we want to leave
europe
with big crash and bang at the end of
the year
have no trade agreement or are we
willing to compromise and walk this back
robert thank you very much that was dw's
brussels correspondent barbara basil